what is going on everybody welcome to
part 19 where matplotlib tutorial series
in this part we're going to be talking
about subplots so there's two major ways
to create subplots so we're going to
cover both of those hopefully in this
tutorial so if you're following along
linearly save the current code that we
have right now but otherwise we're going
to go ahead and just delete all of this
code and we'll restart with a clean
slate basically so I'm going to go
control a delete so first of all we're
going to create some random data so
we're going to use random so I'm just
going to import random and then what
we're going to do is import matplotlib
pipe lot as PLT we always need that so
we'll continue on using that then what
we're going to do is we're going to
define our figure figure is PLT figure
now what we need is some basic data to
start with so we're going to define a
new function and we're going to call
this function create plots and then
we're gonna have X's equals an empty
list wise equals an empty list and then
whereas a for I in range of whatever you
want but we'll do 10 we're going to say
x equals I y equals random dot R and
range and we'll give this a random range
of 10 and then we're going to say X's
dot append the X wise dot append that Y
and then we're all done there and then
at the very end we just returned X's and
Y's so this will give us some sample
data just to kind of work with to get
acclimated to this now what we're going
to do is we're going to find some axes
so as we've seen already we've done
something like this like a x1 equals fig
add underscore sub plot and we've done
something like one by one by one so the
way this works is the first number is
the height the second number is the
width and the third number is plot now
I'm really good at drawing things in
paint so I figure why not draw something
in paint to help everybody so we'll
bring up paint here and the way this
works is the following so we've got a
let's say
we've got a figure here so this is our
figure like the entirety of our graph
and right now we're plotting a one by
one by one so that means the the actual
you know chart is like right in here and
in fact let's make that a let's make it
a different color so black is the figure
and then blue will be the the subplot
okay so that's our current subplot
really nothing special there but what if
we make this a 2 a 2 by 1 and this is
plot number 1 well the way that this
will change is now we have a 2 by 1 so
we'd have 1 plot up here and we'd have
another plot down here so this would be
a 2 by 1 and then this would be plot
number 1 and this would be plot number 2
ok so that's how subplot 2 grid works
and another thing that you might do well
first actually let's let's let's plot 2
examples of this and then we'll go we'll
kind of make this slightly more complex
so we'll say X 1 equals 2 by 1 and its
plot number 1 and then let's go ahead
and just take this copy paste and this
one will be a 2 by 1 and then number 2
and we'll call this axes number 2 so now
what we're going to do is we're just
going to say we'll say X comma y equals
create underscore plots and then we'll
just do a X 1 dot plot and then XY and
then let's just copy this right here
copy whoops sorry punch my mic there
paste and then ax 2 plot XY ok
so let's save and run that and in fact
let's bring in style because we got to
have style so from matplotlib import
style and style die use and we'll use
538 all right save and run that and
we'll wait for that to pop up Serena's
taking a second there we go oh we didn't
call a plot show so we've plotted the
things but we still need PLT touch show
let's try it one more time there we go
so now we've got our plots we've got one
subplot that's up here and one subplot
is down here
we've got a little bit of overlap going
on there but will not worry about that
right now subplot tutorial so anyway so
we've got this plot on the top this so
this is a x1 up here and this is a x2
down here so let's close out of this
cool now what we want to do is let's say
we wanted to add a third subplot but
this time we want maybe we want to
subplots on top so let's say we're
trying to do the following so this would
be you know this would be the the 2x1
this is like you know 2x1 configuration
right but what if we wanted to do like
this like what if we wanted to have a
subplot here a subplot here and then one
big subplot here how do we do that well
the way that we do this is because you
can't say like okay well that's simple
Harrison we would obviously do a 2 by 2
duh well the problem is when you do a 2
by 2 that would be this is plot number
one this is plot number two but what
this one doesn't
you know correspond to anything so
instead what you have to do is you have
basically two grids these top two would
correspond to a two by two and the
bottom one would be still a two by one
two by one but this would be a 2 1 2
this would be a 2 by 2 but plot number 1
and this would be a 2 by 2 and plot
number 2 right and then if say you had a
2 by 2 like like just we're not going to
do this but if you had two more down
here like one there and one here that
would be a you know 2 by 2 number 3 and
a 2 by 2 number 4 ok so if you have
questions about that ask them below but
the way that we're going to get away
with this is by these two are a part of
a 2x2 grid whereas this one is a 2 part
of a 2 by 1 grid so let's go ahead and
bring that bring that out so ax 1 is now
a 2 by 2 number 1 X 2 is a 2 by 2 number
2 and then we'll copy this paste and
then a X 3 will be a 2 by 1
button number two so then let's take
this these information here paste and
then now it's a x3 dot plot XY so now
let's save and run that and sure enough
we've got two graphs on the top and then
one graph on the bottom so that's how
you can do some basic sub plots I
actually this is not my chosen way of
doing sub plots but this way works just
as good as the other way that I'm about
to show you so that's one way that you
can add sub plots but now let's talk
about sub plot to grid so we'll save
this and in fact probably what I'll do
is this would be I'm just going to note
this as add subs add sub plot syntax and
then I'm going to comment all these out
and then now we're going to be talking
about its sub plot to grid so the way
sub plot to grid works is the following
so you would say let's make some space
here and scroll down so you would say ax
1 with subplot 2 grid is equal to PLT
dot sub plot 2 grid and then you specify
the entire grid size so you could kind
of do the exact same thing as you've
done down here but what's good about
subplot 2 grid is remember before when
we had like say we wanted to do like hey
this is a 2 by 2 there was no way to say
like this is 2 by 2 number 1 this is 2
by 2 number 2 and this is 2 by 2 number
2 2 4 right we couldn't do that
but with subplot 2 grid we can so we
don't have to have things having
different grids you know starting sizes
you know so for example here we're gonna
say this is so plot 2 grid it's a part
of a grid that is a 6 by 1 so 6 tall 1
wide but you could do as many wide as
you want it if you want to have multiple
so it's a 6 by 1 and then the next
parameter is the starting point
this one will start at 0 0 and then
we'll have you have two choices here
you've got row span and column span so
let's say
rowspan we want this to span one row
we'll say or actually let's have it
spanned two rows for now and then
colspan will be equal to one
it's really not necessary to add this
because we literally only have one
column but if you wanted to you could
have multiple columns and then you would
still say how many it spans so in our
case now let's see how long it takes us
to clear this up
awesome so now this is subplot to grid
stuff and now what's subplot to grid
does is here's our little figure and
then you know inside it you've got your
subplot grid so it would be you know
something like this I guess and then
within it you've got your little
divisions so this would be we've got six
so this would be one division here there
we go
and then let's just take this copy so we
have two at the moment that would be
three this is our four we've got five
divisions and now we've got six total
divisions here so this is a one two
three four five six by one grid here so
then so that's our grid and then our
little subplots within the grid you
would say okay well at starting point
zero zero let's call this one green now
zero zero let's see we have so it starts
it's a six by one zero zero spans two
rows one column so what would that look
like well that's going to be whoops
that's going to be a subplot that's
basically like this right and then let's
say we had one now we want another one
to be right here the start point here is
going to be two zero and then it would
do let's say we only span one row that
would be like this right or if we said
two rows it would be like this or three
rows it would be like this right and
then so on so now pretty paint aside
let's do it let's say ax one we'll just
copy ax 1 and paste twice so paste paste
ax 2 ax 3 starting point here would be
two starting point here will be four and
then now we can save and run that
and then now you've got you know one two
and three and then moving forward into
the way we're going to do stocks like
let's say we don't want them all the
same size let's make this row span one
this one will be four and this one will
be one starting point here would be one
starting point here would be five right
because this is spanning four you can't
have them overlap but you would not want
to do that but it's possible
so then we'll run that so now we've got
a little squished up chart up here a big
primary chart here and a little squished
up chart down here as far as the labels
are concerned and all this are concerned
don't worry we're going to get into that
but this is kind of the format we're
going to use to plot a stock chart so up
here at the top you would have like an
indicator this would be rear price and
this would be another indicator or
something like that down at the bottom
so we're going to kind of use this
format moving forward with plotting our
stock prices and stuff and the more
advanced customization of matplotlib so
anyways those are you two subplot
options I prefer the second but it
really doesn't matter at the end of the
day they can produce pretty much the
exact same chart so it really doesn't
matter which one you like use whatever
you want we're going to use so plot two
grid for the rest of the series but
really subplot two grid is only used
right here so you can change your add
subplot if you want and follow along for
the rest of the tutorial so do what you
want so plot two grid and subplot that's
it questions comments below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time